now guys we're going to see some amazing
characters return
from the karate kid days so when you're
reading the scripts
realizing these folks are going to be
welcomed back onto the show
what was the sentiment there listen to
me like you taught me everything you
knew
let us find out
it's been a highlight of doing the show
um have and everyone comes with their a
game it really has been
it's such a connection because you have
this history together
even though there's 30 years there's a
scene i have with tamlin
please kumiko where i say god it's been
30 years it feels like
five minutes and that is the truth that
was an honest
uh piece of dialogue i mean that's
there's a there's a spirit among us
and everyone has uh has supported it and
and it's been such having that okinawa
section
in this coming season is really quite
beautiful and informs the story and
informs the side of the russo that you
don't know and he learns something that
he brings
into his story and into the
confrontations with johnny lawrence and
chris and so it's so well written in
that way but having all those actors and
and lisa um you know finally
uh being there when everyone's like when
is that gonna happen
it was it's like lily said it is a big
party but there's something special
about the connection
and you can speak for that as well what
about will smith i see that he's an
executive producer on the show
is he someone that you would like to
have brought into the mix on
you know for the series oh of course i'd
love will be on the
on the show yeah i think we should call
them on yeah we'll give a call
right now ralph yeah we are we are
popular enough that it would be an
easy segue hey not like you're saying
hey could you please do my independent
film that no one will release
i think we have i think we have a scene
with will where we're driving down the
valley and we we see the fresh prince of
bel-air you know
in his house i love it i love it i'd
love to see neil patrick harris on there
as well
just saying yeah well listen
johnny lawrence uh cheerleaders campaign
manager no
i hate ralph macchio i hate him hate him
hate him
he is not the karate kid the karate kid
was william zalka star pupil of the
kobrakai dojo
kobrakai has been giving fans a lot of
entertainment value
during this pandemic time that we've
been living in because it has been at
the top of netflix's streaming charts
during the pandemic because folks have
just wanted more and more of it how does
it feel to be getting this
entirely new audience during these
difficult times that we're in
it's a it's amazing i mean it's just
um it's kind of this show keeps
rebirthing itself
uh to uh to a higher level obviously
with a platform like netflix we're able
to to reach uh many different languages
all over the globe and the karate kid is
one of those films that has resonated
for decades and decades in any language
in every language so
to have that platform for us to have
that embrace
from uh from everyone and and more so
it's not just the nostalgic group that
grew up with the movies it's the
it's the young characters in our show
that have
connected with the young audience and
and then the parents will then watch the
show so you have
fathers and sons and mothers and
daughters you know all talking about the
same thing it's a big
bite of comfort food and so we are
reaping the benefits of that and it's
it's really
really feels uh wonderful so we're gonna
keep it going as long as we can
you've already been renewed for season
four and season three hasn't even come
out officially so
how do you feel i think people are gonna
love it just as much as the first two if
not more and season four is gonna be
is even gonna top that so it's just the
scripts are just better and better the
story keeps moving forward and
uh you know we we get to be on this ride
and you guys all get to come along and
it's a big party you know
and you mentioned ralph uh season three
i tell you guys what
i thought the fight was was rough and
tough in season one season two season
three you guys take it to the next level
it's a little tougher on the body we
tell you know everything
it takes a lot more prep to get ready
you can't just
throw the kick i like you know when you
used to just do something now you do it
i mean it takes me forever to warm up
it's like even standing up in the
morning takes me 15 minutes
but you know so it's all of that it's
preparation
it's uh maybe an occasional
anti-inflammatory the next morning and
walking a little
funny but we're doing it and we take it
seriously and take the best care of
ourselves we
we can what kind of training are you
guys doing william
um i just watch workout videos but jane
fonda come on now
well i just watch them i don't do them i
just watch them uh no
it's uh it's a you know it's a
combination it's a way it's just healthy
living you know
diet first of all you know a lot of
protein like this and that and uh
weight training conditioning and martial
arts which uh you know
it sustains us through through shooting
because it's really the the work that we
do on the show is very vigorous it's
very
very tight tough schedule and we have a
lot to do
so the training isn't just to be in
shape to do the karate the training
actually sustains us to get through this
show
so it's a good thing to it's a good
thing to stay as best in shape as you
can and
and the fighting is a blast it's a lot
of fun but yeah like ralph said you have
to stretch longer and
warm it up but it's right there it's
right there we have a blast doing it